ما هو الجزء الأكثر إثارة للقلق حول
هذا المتغير ba5
جيدًا ، فهو يحتوي على ما نسميه
ميزة الإرسال على
التباين السابق كما تعلم أننا مررنا
بأرقام مختلفة ba1 ba2 ba 2.1 2.1 الآن
لدينا ba5 والذي من الواضح أنه بسبب
قدرته على التهرب من الاستجابات المناعية  إما
من اللقاح أو من الأشخاص الذين
أصيبوا سابقًا بالعدوى ، فإن القدرة على
عدم التأثير على الفرد يتم تعزيزها على
التباين السابق وهذا هو السبب الذي
يجعلك ترى لنا حيث تم الإبلاغ عن 140 أو
أكثر من ألف حالة يوميًا ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون
تقديرًا أقل من الواقع لأن ذلك  يخضع العديد من
الأشخاص للاختبار باستخدام أطقم منزلية
ولا يبلغون عن ذلك ، لذلك من المحتمل أن نشهد
عددًا أكبر بعدة أضعاف من
140 ألف حالة وفاة لا تزال حوالي 300 حالة ، لكن حالات
الاستشفاء في المستشفى تعمل جون على الاستعداد لذلك
هذا شيء لا تريده
الذعر بشأن ذلك ولكننا نحتاج حقًا إلى
الانتباه إليه لأن هناك
أشياء يمكننا القيام بها للتخلص من ذلك ، أعني أنه
ما زلنا لا نملك عددًا كبيرًا من الأشخاص الذين تم
تطعيمهم حيث نحتاج فقط إلى 67 شخصًا.  تم تعزيز
نصف عدد السكان فقط ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى استخدام وسائل
التخفيف المتوفرة لدينا
لإخفاء
الأشخاص الذين لا يقومون بتطعيمهم
وتعزيز الأشخاص المستعدين
والمؤهلين للحصول على دعمهم ، يمكننا القيام بذلك
ولكننا  عدم القيام بذلك إلى الحد
الذي يجب أن نفعله ، يقول إن هذا
المتغير الجديد يزيد من احتمالية
إعادة العدوى للأشخاص الذين أصيبوا به ،
ومدى السرعة التي يمكن أن تُصاب بها مرة أخرى
جيدًا ، كما تعلم ، إنه يختلف حقًا ، جون
أعني عادةً بعد ذلك مباشرة
أصيب في غضون فترة من أسابيع
إلى شهر أو نحو ذلك ، فأنت
محمي إلى حد كبير بسبب الاستجابة المناعية
، تم توثيق إصابة بعض الأشخاص والقيم المتطرفة لديهم
بالعدوى من أسابيع إلى
شهر بعد الإصابة الأولية ولكن في
معظم الأوقات تستمر الحماية
لبضعة أشهر ولكن إذا أصيب شخص ما
منذ عدة أشهر ، خاصة
إذا كان مصابًا بأوميكرون ، فإن
الحماية الممنوحة لك ضد
ba5 تتضاءل وتتضاءل  بسرعة كبيرة
على مدى عدة أشهر إذا
لم تحصل على جرعة معززة هذا العام
أو جرعة اللقاح الثانية إذا
لم تحصل على حقنة في عام 2022 ، إلى أي مدى
تضاءلت مناعتك بشكل
كبير ، أعني عندما تنتظر
الشيء الذي هو  من المهم أن نلاحظ أن
المناعة ضد العدوى تتضاءل
بسرعة كبيرة وتتراجع كثيرًا ما
كنا محظوظين هو أن
المناعة ضد المرض الشديد الذي يؤدي
إلى الاستشفاء ولسوء الحظ
الموت في بعض الحالات يميل إلى الصمود
بشكل معقول ولكنه ينزلق حيث
كان.  حتى 90 80 ثم تنخفض إلى
70 75 65 و 50 ، فأنت حقًا في
موقف تحتاج فيه حقًا إلى
دفعة ونعلم أنه عندما تخرج ستة
سبعة أشهر أو لذلك نحن الآن في يوليو
في الشهر السابع من العام ،
يعاني معظم الأشخاص الذين لم يتلقوا
جرعة معززة هذا العام من ضعف
المناعة